hi everyone
unfortunately I've got some sad news
as you may have noticed this channel has
been rather quiet recently and as some
of you may have seen on my socials and
patrons will have learned from the
behind the scenes Vlogs this has been
because my dad's been very sick and I've
been assisting as I can with his care
unfortunately the care that he's been
receiving a hospital and more recently
at home
has been palliative we found out last
November that he had a slow growing
bowel cancer and in January this year we
found out that it was now rapidly
growing and was actually terminal
and last week he passed away at the age
of 68. some of you may remember my dad
from a few of my older videos it is
impossible to try and communicate to you
quite what he means to me and what a
profound silence his loss has introduced
into my life
but I do think that in those videos you
do get a sense of what kind of man he
was
he was kind and gentle and very funny
and
deeply compassionate and deeply
intelligent
he was
the best role model the best father
figure I could have ever wished for
and now he's gone as such I am going to
be taking some time away from work to
spend time with my family and to get his
Affairs in order I'm not going to be
making videos for
a while I honestly don't know how long
it's going to be until I feel up to
writing and being on camera again
maybe a month I I don't know videos will
be coming out on this channel though in
the near future they're just not going
to be from me while I'm on leave I asked
some friends of mine from the community
that's built up around my work to make
some videos about their research
interests so you're going to be seeing
videos from cat a PhD student at the
University of bath and Thomas a master
student at the University of Saint
Andrews unfortunately my YouTube channel
is frankly just not in a good spot right
now views are very very down and I'm
obviously doing something wrong
algorithmically because my videos are
just not being recommended to people so
my hope is that these guest videos I
asked Thomas and Kat made these guest
videos so that the channel can just keep
ticking over and try and keep at least a
little bit of momentum going such that
when I come back
um I have a Fighting Chance of actually
still having this job as well of course
as this being a great opportunity for
cat and Thomas who make their own
content elsewhere to get a bit of a
signal booster leg up please do watch
their videos when they come out and
leave some feedback leave some
constructive criticism in the comments
and maybe go follow them on their own
channels I will be making a video about
this experience and more importantly
raising money for Dorothy house the
cancer hospice where Dad spent his last
couple of days at some point in the
future but for now
this is it I I just want to close by
saying
hug your loved ones everyone tell them
how you feel
because
while we may feel like we have a really
long time here
our time is finite
enjoy the guest videos
and I'll see you at some point hopefully
soon